Hi, welcome back. In this session, I'd
like to focus on activist growth
investing. If you remember in the
context of value investing, we talked
about activist value investing. What
private equity investors and others
come into a company, take a position,
and then try to actively change the way
the company is run. In active growth
investing, that role is usually played
by venture capitalists who come in and
provide capital to young startups and
young growth firms, and then try to mold
the way those firms grow, sometimes in
good ways and sometimes in bad ways. So,
let's get the process started.
If you look at the face of activist
growth
investing, it usually takes the form of
venture capital.
But, venture capital is just a term.
Prior to the existence of venture
capital as we know it, there always been
people who've invested in young growth
firms, private individuals, wealthy
people, institutions.
What do they hope to get? They hope to
have success in getting that young
growth firm become a large mature firm,
and reap the harvest.
So, if you look at activist growth
investing, the most common form is
investing in young startups, venture
capitalists provide, but now
increasingly over time, public equity
investors have entered the space as have
wealthy individuals.
It is also possible,
but now very uncommon, it's possible
that there are some growth companies,
publicly traded companies which have run
into issues with their growth investing,
where an activist investor like a
private equity investor comes in and
changes the way that publicly traded
firm is run.
Uncommon, and in the case of growth
companies, you're far more likely to see
activist investing take the form of
venture capital.
So, let's take a closer look at
investing in private equity and all of
the different forms. As I said, venture
capitalists have their history in the US
going back to the 1950s.
But, one of the first was American
Research, and over time US venture
capital has been way ahead of the rest
of the world in being able to provide
seed money to young startups.
The 1980s,
there was private equity in the form of
leverage buyout, but they didn't look at
young growth firms. They looked at
mature and declining firms.
And as in we talked about in earlier
session, private equity funds have
exploded as the desire for alternative
investing has come from that end game of
clients wanting to invest.
As the as the private equity business
has exploded, you also saw the alphas
and the excess returns fade away.
In this session, I want to focus
primarily on the venture capital
process.
So, let's take a look at how the venture
capital process works. Let's say you're
an entrepreneur.
You have a startup.
It's doing well. You have lots of
promise, but you need capital.
You approach a venture capital.
You make a You make a pitch and you get
the venture capital in. That's the first
step in the process, right? A young
startup getting the interest of a
venture.
Now, in some cases, it's not you seeking
out the venture capitalist. A venture
capitalist might seek you out because
they've heard that you have promise.
That's the first step though, is that
connection.
The second step in the process, a
venture capitalist tries to put a price
on your company. Keyword is price, not
value of company as we'll see in a few
in a in a minute or so.
There's very little valuation in venture
capital. It's all about pricing and
we'll talk about the basis for that
pricing. And why do you need a pricing?
Because if a venture capitalist is going
to invest money in your company, the
proportion of your company he or she
will demand in return will depend on the
pricing of your company. Now, let's take
a simple example. Let's assume you're
seeking out a 100 million in venture
capital.
To determine what portion of your
company you want to give up in return
for the 100 million, you've got to come
up with a pricing for the company. If
your pricing for your company is 500
million, the 100 million will give the
venture capitalist a 20% stake.
Already, you can see pricing is going to
be this issue where founders and venture
capitalists are going to be pushing from
opposite directions.
Incidentally, in venture capital, there
is this distinction that's drawn between
pre-money and post-money pricing.
At the risk of getting into quicksand
here, let me give you a very simple way
of thinking about the difference.
The pre-money pricing of a private
business is what that private business
is worth if it continues on its existing
path without getting the venture capital
influx.
The post-money pricing is what that same
business is worth with the venture
capital influx coming in. You're saying,
"What difference is the venture capital
influx going to make?" At first sight,
there is a very simple change that
happens, right? If I raise 100 million
from venture capital, the minute after I
do that, I've got 100 million in cash.
So, many people they talk about
pre-money and post-money pricing, all
they do is they price the company and
then they add the cash raised in the in
the venture capital round to that
pricing. That's you know, that's
it's it's it's a lazy way of distinction
you know, distinguishing between pre-
and post-money pricing. You're saying,
"What's the right way to do it?" You
actually have to va-
the funds coming in, which mean it might
grow slower. It It It's going to be a
different business. And then you revalue
the business with the money coming in,
opening doors to maybe more growth and
more ambition.
Pre-money and post-money pricing
captures the difference in addition to
the cash influx.
Second, once you seek out that venture
capitalist as a founder,
that money is going to come with strings
because the venture capitalist part
owner of the company, they're going to
put constraints on not just how you run
the business, but how you raise
additional capital. Think about it. If
you invest in a startup and you don't
constrain the owner, the owner can very
quickly undercut you by going out and
raising fresh equity and giving them an
earlier stake, a better stake than you
do. So, venture capital in addition to
providing money to a company and getting
a piece of the company, will put in
restrictions on future capital raises.
Now, and and those those constraints
might come into play as you try to grow.
That's a process of venture capital.
Let's talk about how venture capitalists
price startups.
Key word as I said is pricing. If you
remember the way we price things, we
look at other things just like the thing
we're pricing and what people pay for
them. In the context of venture capital,
it's usually the you know, pricing a
private business. You look at other
private businesses
that other venture capitalists have
priced. So, you can look at pricing of
similar companies.
That's one basis. So, if you're putting
your money in an AI firm, you could look
at 50 other AI firms and see what what
venture capital have priced the firms
at. One of the problems you're going to
have in pricing these companies,
especially early in the process, is they
don't have the financial metrics usually
scale the pricing to. Remember you
divide by earnings, which you're
definitely not going to have with a
startup. Even revenues might not be
there. So, often you get desperate, you
divide by price per user, price per
download, price per potential market,
but you scale the pricing.
The The other thing you can do is look
at recent pricing of the same company.
If you take a company like Uber, which
had 10, 12, 15 rounds of venture
capital, the most recent venture capital
round might have been 3 months ago and
those people might have priced the
company at 100 billion, in which case
that's going to be a starting point.
Pricing
of similar companies.
But ultimately, if your end game is to
go public, you're going to be looking at
the pricing of public companies.
Staying in the AI space again, if
publicly traded AI companies are being
priced at 50 times revenues, that's
going to feed into your pricing of
private businesses in that space as
well. But, it's all pricing. The notion
that venture capitalists sit down and go
through business models and value
companies is false. That's not what they
do.
In fact, one common variant of venture
capital pricing is a forward pricing.
Why do you do a forward pricing? Because
as I said, most startups don't have much
of substance now. No revenues, no
earnings.
So, you project out into a future year
when you think they will have revenues.
So, let's say that in year five, you
expect your startup to have a hundred
million dollars in revenues. It's an
expectation.
You apply a multiple to those revenues
based on what? Based on public
companies, based on other companies that
have revenues right now. Let's say those
companies right now trade at five times
revenues. You take a hundred million,
you multiply by five, you get the
expected pricing in year five, five
hundred million dollars.
You're almost there.
You need a pricing today. What do you
have to do? You have to bring that money
back to today.
Venture capitalists apply what's called
a target rate of return. Looks like a
discount rate, acts like a discount
rate, but we're going to talk about why
it's really not a traditional discount
rate.
But, you discount it back to today.
Because as a venture capitalist, here
are the things you worry about. That the
company might not make it.
That there might be additional cash
required and more capital raised. So,
all of those things are going to play
into the target rate of return.
So, you discount back that five hundred
million today using that target rate of
return. The higher the target rate, the
more the discounting effect is going to
lower that number.
In some cases, you just compute an IRR
based on that number to see if you're
earning a reasonable return.
So, you already can see the game that
goes on. If you play the role of the
founder and I play the role of the
venture capitalist,
remember your end game as the founder is
to push up the pricing so you can end up
giving up less of your company. And my
objective as a venture capitalist is to
move in the other direction. So, I'm
going to push for lower expected
revenues in year five, a lower multiple,
and a higher target rate, and you're
going to push for the exact opposite.
That's how venture capitalists put a
number on companies. And that, of
course, is kind of this amorphous
number. Is it pre-money or post-money?
You know, it
because it's such a back-of-the-envelope
calculation, I'm not sure what you
priced when you did this. So, it's kind
of messy. So, when you see pre-money and
post-money pricing, remember you're
working off a number that's a
back-of-the-envelope number,
for lack of a better description.
So, let's say you've negotiated a
pricing, you've given up a stake in your
in your in your young company to a
venture capitalist. The venture
capitalist doesn't go away. In fact,
venture capital investing cannot be
passive investing. Where you put your
money in a company and just walk back
and do live the rest of your life,
you've got to take an active role.
Because if you don't, you're going to
get ripped off.
So, to begin with, there's some good
stuff that venture capitalists can bring
into a startup. They can bring in
management experience, building supply
chains, the kind of
knowledge about building a business you
might not have as a founder. They can
come with a Rolodex, using an
old-fashioned term, or a contact list
that'll allow you to raise more capital.
So, there's that post-deal component
they bring in.
But as they're doing all of this,
venture capital is always checking out
the exit door. Because to make money as
a venture capitalist,
you have to do one of three things.
One is you take the company public. This
is the most glamorous exit because your
small private business becomes a public
business. Your 20% stake in what used to
be a billion-dollar firm is now a 20%
stake in a hundred-billion-dollar firm.
That's an initial public offering. You
say, "Why doesn't every startup do
this?" Because it might not be an option
for your startup if you don't get to
that scale, right?
Usually, venture capitalists don't
liquidate their holdings at the time of
the offering, but they're looking for an
exit nevertheless, 6 months, a year,
where they can dump their share or
reduce their share.
The second alternative is to sell the
private business to another firm,
publicly traded or otherwise, at a price
hopefully higher than the price you
estimate the time you entered.
The third alternative, it's uncommon,
is let the private business run as a
private business, and as it matures, it
throws off cash flows, you collect the
cash flows.
It's un- unlikely that this is going to
be a great return strategy, but it might
be a strategy for some of the
investments in your venture capital
portfolio.
So, the pricing, you got the post-deal
management.
But let's talk about the biggest risk in
venture capital. This graph, which comes
from the Bureau of Labor Statistics,
which tracks the number of startups in
every in the US, and then tracks what
happens to them by sector over time.
Take a look at all firms, right?
You start off with 100 firms. By the
time you get to the end of year one, you
only 80 firms. You're saying, "What
happened to the other 20?" They failed.
In fact, by the time you get to the end
of year seven,
almost 70% of the companies you started
with have failed.
To venture capitalists, this is your
primary risk. Many of the startups you
invest in will never make it. You're
saying, "I can liquidate them, and get
what?" Many of them don't have assets
you can sell, right? You're probably
going to get nothing from your
investment.
So, when you're a venture capitalist,
you worry about this constantly.
And then you try to bring it into the
analysis. And there are two ways venture
capitalists try to do it.
First is by hiking up that target rate,
and that's why I said it's not quite a
discount rate, because it becomes this
mechanism that venture capitalists use
to capture survival risk and cash burn
risk and everything else.
So, the more worried you're about
failure and survival, the higher the
target rate becomes and the lower the
value today becomes.
You also try to bring it in in other
ways, in back doors, by using more
conservative estimates of revenues in
the future,
lower values for the exit multiple, but
all of those things are helping you
become more conservative in your pricing
and demand a higher stake. Of course,
founders will push back in the opposite
direction, but it's a venture capitalist
way of dealing with survival risk.
And as I said, target rates of return
are concoctions.
The typical discounted cash flow
valuation and discount rate is supposed
to reflect the risk in an ongoing
business. In fact, discounted cash flow
valuation is designed for going
concerns. It's not designed for survival
risk.
And the problem with target rates, it
becomes a blunt instrument. You just
puff it up to include all of these other
worries. It becomes a receptacle for all
of your fears.
Now, of course, venture capitalists
charge different target rates for
different kinds of VC investments.
Angel investing, which is very young
companies, you might demand a much
higher target rate than investing in
startups that are further along the road
to developing a business. But in
general, venture capital target rates,
if you take a look at them and they're
in the public domain, look very high,
40, 50, 60, 70%, and therein lies one
reason that the myth of venture
capitalists being great investors is
born, because you look at those target
rates and say, "These guys must be
amazing. How the heck do they earn 50,
60, or 70% returns?" The answer is, they
don't.
In fact, if you look at the actual
returns that venture capitalists earn,
they're very ordinary.
They look very similar to what you and I
make investing in the S&P 500 or what
private equity investors make.
In fact, over very long time periods,
venture capitalists are worth So, if you
look at a 20-year time it's worth about
1.2% more than the S&P 500. And
definitely less than what those target
rates are.
So, when you see those target rates of
return and you discount that terminal
price back, be very careful. This is not
a discount rate in the conventional
sense of the word. You won't be able to
explain it using any of the traditional
metrics. It's a bargaining device used
to capture survival risk and other risks
that venture capitalists worry about.
So, on average venture capitalists are
not super investors. They're pretty
average investors. And if you look by
group at early stage, late stage, I
mean, at every stage, I mean, let's
start with the No, in individual years
you might have great years, but if you
look at longer time periods
you look at all venture capitalists,
they earn about 18%. That's good, right?
Over a 20-year period. Early stage
venture capitalists earn the highest
returns, but then you get to later
stages, it starts looking very much like
public equity.
You look at the table, you're saying,
"I'm going to be an early stage venture
capitalist. That's where the big returns
are."
A caveat. One is
those returns at early stage investments
tend to be incredibly skewed. What I
mean by that is if you have a hundred
very young startup investments, you'll
be lucky if 20 of them pay off. And the
three or five that pay off the most pay
off in such a big way that they make up
for the rest.
This is true in venture capital
portfolios. Venture capital portfolios
are not built where you get most of your
investments paying off. It's your those
big payoff investments.
Now, in the in If you use the
terminology of finance, there's a lot of
optionality. Venture capitalists invest
in options rather than traditional
businesses. And the options that pay off
are deep out of the money options. So,
they pay off big time and they make up
for your losses on all of your others.
So, as you look at startups and
late-stage investments, you're going to
see that especially with startups, it's
very skewed. It gets less skewed with
late stage. And the later you go in the
life cycle,
the more symmetric the distribution
start to become.
So, on average, venture capitalists look
average. I know deliver returns
that look very much like average public
market investors.
But if you look at the biggest winners
in venture capital, they tend to get
those gains by being in,
as an example, Benchmark Capital,
investing in Uber at a billion-dollar
pricing.
Company goes public at 100 billion.
That's the kind of investment that
delivers the returns.
Now, one thing that you can say in
venture capital's favor is unlike in
other aspects of investing, the most
successful venture capitalist
tend to stay successful. As opposed to
what? The most successful public market
equity investors keep flipping, right?
They go from one year to the next. You
There's very little continuity in
investing
in other spaces. But in venture capital,
there seems to be a lot of continuity.
There's something about the venture
capital business that allows the most
successful venture capitalist to have
durable competitive advantages
that allow them to keep winning.
And what might those advantages be?
One is perhaps they're better pricers
than the rest of the tribe. Or perhaps,
and this might also happen, once you get
successful, private companies want your
money so much that they offer you better
pricing. So, you if you're
if you're one of the top venture
capitalist and I'm a startup, I might
come to you and offer a share of my
company at a much better pricing than I
demand of other venture capitalists. So,
whether they get better prices or they
just get a better pricing, you start at
a much better spot if you get a bigger
stake in a company for a given venture
capital investment. Second,
they can influence the pricing game. If
you raise money from a success from one
of the top venture capitalists, it makes
it easier for you to raise more money.
Now, SoftBank has had a very mixed
record in in in venture capital, but the
fact they have so much money to invest
it means that once SoftBank invests,
other VCs line up to invest as well
because they know there's more money
where that came from.
And I think the very best venture
capitalists are like the very best
traders. They have good timing. What
does that mean? They get in at the right
time. They get out at the right time.
I like to tell the story of Mark Cuban,
legendary venture capitalist, right? But
if you look at that legend, he created a
company called broadcast.com that he
sold at the peak of the dot-com boom for
$5 billion.
You know what happened to broadcast.com
in the aftermath of the of the dot-com?
It went away.
If we judge Mark Cuban based on the
quality of the business he built, not a
great business, right? But if you judge
him as a venture capitalist, he's a
great venture capitalist because he got
in at the right time, he got out at the
right time.
The very best venture capitalists share
the same kinds of characteristics as
very best traders. They get in at the
right time, they get out at the right
time.
So, if you decide to go this route of
investing in young startups,
the key for you is to pick
the companies to invest in well. And
because these companies are in form, you
care more about who's running the
companies. Good founder/managers
matter a lot more cuz they're the ones
who going to build the business.
The very best venture capitalists
are as
are better judges of people than average
venture capitalists.
You got to spread your bets. As you saw,
it's a very skewed distribution where a
few big winners carry you. So, you got
to spread your bets. If you put all your
money in one startup, God help you. You
got to spread your bets, preferably
across different types of Even if you're
a tech venture capitalist, spreading it
across all aspects of tech rather than
just AI is better for you.
Third, your job doesn't end.
You got to be a consultant. You got to
be an advisor. In some cases, you might
actually have to push founders out and
bring new people in if the founder's
incapable of building a business.
Fourth, you got to protect your
investment as the firm grows and raises
more capital. So, there you got to make
sure you put in protections when you
invest. So, when the company goes out
and raises more capital,
you can make sure the terms on that
capital don't undercut you. And you
know, you have to know when to get out.
A good exit strategy is what's going to
make you successful.
If all of those things work in your
favor,
a venture capital route opens up to you.
I hope you found the session useful, and
I thank you very much for listening.